we're in a bit of a predicament  the man was killed  please think that we did it  and we need to clear our names oh that's  something  he was killed because of something that  he had seen  because of an organization we want to  rule the world  rule the world  we need you good people to help us out  it's the only hope that we have to get  out of this situation well let's hope  this goes well  things got more complicated  do you want to start this  drinks on me  literally  [Music]  there's more where this came from  let's go to amsterdam  amsterdam rated r did someone slap you  bert cause you have a red mark on your  face i got slapped i got punched oh no  no no only in theaters october 7th